domestic water that's provided to our
homes today comes through a series of
water treatment processes and piping and
pumps and you know things that bring
that water to us today and then the
wastewater is returned back to treatment
to treatment plants a couple of
challenges those municipalities are
facing one is that the infrastructure is
aging it's leaking there's between a lot
of cities have between 30 and 60 percent
of the water that they produce never
makes it to the end of the line because
it leaks out of these pipes it's
difficult for them to replace it because
there just isn't the reserve the revenue
to be able to invest in this replacement
one of the other challenges is it's very
energy intensive between three and
twenty percent of a typical
municipalities budget goes to energy to
produce and pump this water around so we
look at smart grid type of technology
not unlike we see in the energy smart
grid is necessary for water to really to
improve this system part of that is to
be able to detect where are these leaks
to be able to be predictive to get out
ahead so instead of waiting for a leak
to occur and having that you know all of
the emergency digging up the roads you
know all the problems that that might
cause be nice to be able to predict when
might that failure occur to be able to
predict what are the costs over the next
year or the next decade in that that
infrastructure we as consumers if we
really understood where our water was
was going and we had some control over
that and we could you know use the water
and off-peak hours all the same type of
things that we try to do with the energy
grid I think it would really improve our
overall consumptive habits of water
another thing is that there the water
pricing structure is it's a real
challenge for us today many parts of the
world including many parts of United
States basically water is free and so as
long as water is free or highly
subsidized there's really there's
there's kind of no incentive for us to
reduce our consumption or change our
behaviors so I think a smart system
would give us that insight that we need
to really change behaviors because I do
think people want to want to be smart
consumers of our water but without that
information it's very difficult to make
those those smart decisions
there's a lot of really smart
technologies being deployed now in
cities a couple of examples a Singapore
has been brilliant in the way that
they're thinking about their have the
overall broad scope of their water
system for many years Singapore relied
on Malaysia for the supply of their
water a giant pipeline coming from
Malaysia to Singapore and over the last
decade or so they've been very proactive
in trying to diversify their water
supply so for instance they now have a
program they refer to as the four taps
they have four different ways that they
get water one is that pipeline from
Malaysia the second is through very
advanced reuse water wastewater reuse
technologies that they've deployed so
that a significant portion of their over
water overall water supply actually
comes from treated waste water streams
fantastic technology the third is around
the capture of rainwater you know a lot
of rain in Singapore but most of it runs
off so now what they've been able to do
is build a series of reservoirs and
catchment basins to catch in purify that
water and then forth they use
desalination technology to kind of make
up the difference so between these four
various technologies smart
infrastructure system to monitor they
really are brilliant in the way they've
put a long-term plan together around
their water supply
future really is one of the major
solutions for our future water challenge
is going to be reuse of water and you
know there's often a negative
connotation to that people think Oh
toilet to tap we've heard to flush to
brush shower to flower so a lot of
different thoughts but really the beauty
of wastewater reuse is we can actually
purify that wastewater way beyond the
quality needed for for drinking water in
fact it's a nice consistent high quality
water now people don't have much issue
with desalination to be able to take
seawater and make drinking water and
actually waste water is much easier to
treat than seawater but independent of
that that negative reaction to
wastewater reuse if you think about it
ninety percent of the world's water is
not used for human consumption or for
domestic use so we've got a great
opportunity to treat and reuse our
wastewater for agricultural irrigation
for industrial uses for a lot of other
uses before we ever get to the point
where we have to use it for you know
direct potable water reuse so today we
see a lot of adaptation of reuse water
to take the load off of streams and
rivers and fresh water supplies to be
used in industrial plants
another great area related to water
reuse is this idea of waste to value how
you take a waste stream don't look at
that as a as a liability anymore there's
a lot of goodies in your in waste water
for instance in a municipal wastewater
system tremendous amount of carbon
content which you can convert to energy
so this idea of having a wastewater
plant that is that is carbon neutral or
actually generates you know more power
than it consumes a tremendous
opportunity phosphorus is a dwindling
resource globally yet there's a lot of
phosphorus and waste streams so there's
some cool technologies coming out
they're going to be able to selectively
remove things like phosphate or metals
like copper from a waste stream and be
able to process those into a finished
product so we need to stop thinking
about a wastewater stream as as pure
waste and look at that as a as an asset
not unlike we've been looking at you
know if you think about recycled
aluminum and plastic and all that used
to be a pure waste stream that's now raw
material for for other processes so
wastewater in the future will be a raw
material for many processes
of water is a real that's a hot topic
we're where we stand with the price of
water is it needs to be priced relative
to the value received from that water
often where water is underpriced or not
priced for value there's no real
incentive to reduce consumption or
change behaviors and so the most
important thing I think relative to
price is that it has to be priced
according to the investments made to get
that water to you know people say water
is a human right and I completely agree
what is not necessarily a human right or
free is that treatment and transport of
the water to get it conveniently to us
so I think the most important thing is
that people realize the value of that
water you know today our water bill in
most parts of the world is much less
than our cable bill much less than our
monthly cell phone bill and yet you
could certainly live without those long
before you can live without water so we
we are encouraging the world to look
more wisely yet water pricing and one of
the challenges regarding price for
instances agriculture seventy percent of
the world's water supply goes to our
agricultural markets for irrigation so
if you think about it today if we
subsidize the price of water for
irrigation and there's really no desire
on a you know farmers part to spend a
lot of money for low-flow irrigation or
smarter irrigation technologies because
it really is a cost to them instead if
we would think of those subsidies for
low-flow irrigation for smart
technologies you know net net the farmer
doesn't pay any more but we as a society
have much more water available than for
our own consumption